let's all leak code 53 maximum sub-array
so we're given an integer array of
gnomes and we want to find the
contiguous sub array containing at least
one number which has the largest sum and
then we want to return only the sum so
this array has in positive numbers and
it has negative numbers so that's what
we have to keep in mind in this case the
largest sum is 6 and it's just this
middle portion of the array so the first
thing you might try is just compute
every single sub array right so let's
first compute every single subarray
starting at negative 2 there's one sub
array there's 2 sub arrays there's 3 sub
arrays and then we keep doing that until
we got to the end right and then we
could repeat the process for the second
number so the sub array starting at 1
here another sub array starting at 1
here all the way until the end
now we could repeat that same process
for every number in the array so let's
just write the pseudocode to see what
that what kind of complexity this would
yield so let's say we're starting the
eye is gonna represent the starting
value it's gonna be it's gonna range
from zero all the way to the last number
n minus 1 or the last index and minus 1
and then we want to get the ending index
so I'm going to use J for the end of
this sub array so we're gonna start at I
and we're going to keep going until the
end of the sub array or until the end of
the entire array and minus 1 so this
represents the start I represents the
start J represents the end now we
actually want to compute the sum of this
sub array so we're gonna have a third
loop for that right let's use KK is
gonna range all the way from I to J
right because that's what represents the
sub array and then in here we'd compute
the sum right now obviously this is
really inefficient right the time
complexity is n cubed it's obvious
because we have 3 for loops so let's try
to expand upon this let's see if we can
make any shortcuts to improve it so the
most obvious thing you'll probably
notice is that we can save time when
we're computing a sub array so if let's
say we computed this sub array right and
we want to compute the next sub-array
was just one added element well we can
save the result of this right and say
it's our current summer or whatever and
then to compute this sub array we just
have to add this number over here right
so we can just say current sum plus
negative 1 and so this can save us time
let's take a look at the time complexity
of this solution so we're going to have
another for loop which is going to
represent the start so start is going to
range from 0 all the way to n minus 1
and we're gonna have another loop for
the end of the sub array
J is going to range from I 2 the last
index n minus 1 and then inside of the
loop we're going to maintain our current
sum and simply just add the number J
each iteration of the loop right so this
is a little more efficient o of N
squared it's a pretty easy optimization
to make and it improves your solution a
lot but can we do even better than this
so now the question you should ask
yourself is do we have to compute every
sub array starting at every single value
in the array right do we have to start
at every single value and compute every
sub array that comes after it I don't
think we do remember we're trying to
find the maximum sub array we can use
that knowledge to help us make a
shortcut so let's take a look at this we
have a negative 2 right so when we're
starting here that's gonna be our max
sum so far then we get to negative 2
plus 1 so this is negative 1 so far
right do we actually need this negative
number the negative numbers don't
contribute anything in this case right
so we can disk we can basically ignore
that value right once we get here we can
basically say this negative value this
negative prefix that came before
positive 1 isn't gonna help us at all so
let's not even consider it
so next do we get to this negative 3 now
up until here our total sum is negative
2 right so then we get to this 4 this is
a negative prefix that came before
negative too right so we can say up
until this point we're not even gonna
consider what came before so this one
and negative three aren't gonna help us
at all just ignore them now we get to a
negative one so the prefix that came
before this was a positive four so we're
gonna not delete it from our list we're
gonna keep that positive four and add it
to this negative one so now we're gonna
be a three so far now we get to a
positive two right even though there's a
negative one that came before it well
there was a positive forward that came
before that so if we get rid of this
negative one we also have to get rid of
the positive four which we don't want to
do remember we have to keep the
sub-array contiguous so I'm not gonna
chop this portion off I'm gonna keep it
now now we're gonna add two to it so now
we're gonna be at five then we're gonna
get this one we're gonna add it and get
our sub array of six and this is the
result so far but let's keep going and
see what happens next will have a
negative five right so minus five now
we're at one so obviously we decreased
our sub array but we know this negative
five is not going to be deleted because
we had a positive six portion comprised
of these four elements that were that
came before that
lastly we get a positive four again add
that our sum is still five so we see
that the max of our a was this portion
of these four elements which totaled to
six now this was a linear time algorithm
it's kind of like a sliding window right
we keep incrementing our right pointer
as we go as we go through the array
right but our left pointer keeps getting
shifted if we ever have a negative
prefix like this negative two or this
negative two portion comprised of these
two elements so anytime we get a
negative prefix we remove it and for me
it kind of helps it kind of helps me to
think about this as like a sliding
window and since it's a linear time
algorithm the overall time complexity is
Big O of n we didn't need any extra
memory we just had to go through the
array removing any negative prefix as we
computed the total sum okay so now let's
code it
so we can initialize our Max sub-array
to the first value in the array that's
like the default value that we're going
to give it because we have to give it
something and it can't be zero because
we know we have negative values in this
array and we know the array is non empty
so the zeroth value of the array is
always going to exist and we're going to
be constantly computing our current sum
so I'm going to initialize that to zero
so let's go through each number in nomes
now remember if we had a negative prefix
we're going to remove that portion from
our current sum so the way that we can
check this is just check if current sum
is at any point negative if it's less
than zero we're just going to reset it
back to zero and then after that we can
add our current number to this this will
make sure that we're always computing
the maximum that we can now this current
sum could be the possible maximum so
we're just going to update our max sub
array to the maximum of itself as well
as the max that we just computed after
we're done with that we'll return
whatever we computed as the max sub
array I hope this helps show you kind of
the intuition behind the solution of
this problem if it was helpful
leave a like and subscribe and thank you
for watching